so wait you were also mirabelle's Father
in Encanto which I was literally still
plays in my house thank you
full movie I mean you know we're working
with Disney is is a it's a dream yeah
you you get to do these things that
um first of first and foremost to be a
part of a movie that meant so much to so
many people at a time where they really
needed that Joy
um was just different
um it was a very different type of movie
too it was a very different type of
movie for Walt Disney but it was the joy
of my life to be a part of that and to
be the 60th film for uh the um Walt
Disney Animation Studios it was was
pretty pretty iconic too so the whole
thing was crazy I mean even even going
to the premiere you know and seeing it
all you know the colorful the red carpet
and the whole thing and
um
Kelly the thing that that I think about
when I think about that Premiere was
being able to bring my mother to the
premiere for many reasons because you
know she's Colombian yeah and the movie
takes place in a small little village in
Colombia
and for my mother in her lifetime for
her to be able to see
you know her Colombia portrayed on
screen
um as anything but what it's been you
know for decades and decades it's been
it was really really beautiful and then
uh something she didn't get to see
probably as a child you know for sure
like she didn't see that when she was a
kid no well Colombia was a very
different uh country but even like on
screen like I don't feel like this is
the first time it's cool for my kids too
to be introduced to a culture that they
don't know much about like they're
obsessed we have that freaking candle
lit in our house all the time like we
have literally they sent me all the
Silverman condo and I swear to God it's
an Inca it looks like I'm obsessed with
Colombian culture and yeah I'm just like
but they love it and it's a cool way to
introduce it to people that are aren't
aware and it's also a cool way like
representation like yeah did you have
anything like that when you're a kid to
look up to anybody that you know yeah I
mean I think there's very few people
that that speak to you and specifically
for the Latinos you know and back in
film and television
um most of the characters that were
portrayed were unfortunately not
necessarily who you wanted to grow up
being you know yeah they were like
Typecast yeah they were very Time cast
they were they were very stereotypical
characters you know and
um but when I look back I look at this
one man you know uh Desi Arness right
who played oh my God Ricky Ricardo I
Love Lucy yeah and I was obsessed too
and uh and you know I used to watch it
in Spanish which was I didn't know it
was really really funny I used to watch
it in Spanish back in Venezuela and I
told you something that's really really
unique
um when I looked at him and I saw him on
this show he was speaking Spanish to me
as a child
you know and not until when I came to
the United States I realized oh they're
speaking English you know
but the point is that I I felt like I
could be him yeah and that I felt like
that was someone that sounded like me
that looked like me and originally you
know I was speaking in Spanish I was
like oh anybody can be that now you know
and then you come to the United States
and you watch him do his thing with an
accent and um so he was someone that
that inspired me not only as an artist
but also as an entrepreneur and as a
producer and yeah he's someone that done
so much for television I don't know if
you guys knew but he he created the
multi-camera multi-cam format for
sitcoms you can watch the documentary
and find that and the movie there's like
two different things the documentary is
just as cool as well yeah I got my
mother and I just deep dough on
Christmas and just watched the whole and
we're like oh my God because I love this
show growing up like most kids would
want to watch something you're not
supposed to watch I would go past my
bedtime because it'd come on at 10 30
P.M to watch I Love Lucy like I that's
who I am
but what a Magic combination when you
think about uh Lucy and and Desi
together uh what Ricky and Lucy right um
is chemistry this this which was beyond
culture back then it was beyond what you
looked like it was just an energy So
Different yeah yeah I loved it
[Music]
[Applause]